warum ist es in jenen augen so wichtig
dass die schüler wirklich in den
klassenraum kommen und dort direkt
unterrichtet werden also zunächst mal
hat ja der doktor und ganz lage zeigt
wie schwierig lernen am computer ist wir
wissen sowieso dass der computer ära
plenk und stört und es gibt auch studien
quader aus holland jetzt eine maschinen
die an 350.000 schülern gezeigt hat und
holland ist dann sehr digitalisiertes
land und die schulen sind auch
digitalisiert haben erfahrung was haben
die schüler gelernt gar nichts und wenn
man sich das überlegt dann denke ich mir
ist wichtig dass man schulen wenn es
irgend geht aufhalten sollte denn
letztlich lernen und lehren funktioniert
am besten eben mit menschen
untereinander und was immer man tun muss
zum beispiel masken tragen oder zum
beispiel bestimmte distanz regeln
einhalten ist immer besser wenn es die
schule erlaubt offen zu lassen als die
schulen zu schließen oder durch digitale
lehre zu ersetzen die funktioniert je
jünger die menschen sind umso schlechter
schon bei studenten die die leiden und
der digitale lehre die wir jetzt alle
machen müssen an der universität und die
sagen es ist nicht so gut wie live und
je jünger die menschen sind desto
schwieriger kommen so mit digitalen
medien klar und das liegt einfach an der
gehirnentwicklung und nicht erfolgt ist
die man aber braucht wenn man digitale
medien nutzen wir deswegen schulen ich
kann nur sagen wir haben bislang sehr
gut gemacht schulen offen halten so
lange es geht und mit allen maßnahmen
die das unterstützen
und wenn man jetzt sagt wir teilen die
klassen okay wenn dann die schule noch
geht wenn man vielleicht dann irgendwie
das so hinkriegt dass es auch wirklich
machbar ist ich denke das hängt von der
schule sehr stark ab man kann auch
vormittags unterrichten und nachmittags
und es ist eben jetzt notfall da müssen
alle mitmachen
der mediziner arbeiten doppelt so viel
und es ist einfach normal weil jetzt
notfall ist das trifft sich ja für
andere bewusst wurden dann eben auch mal
zu bin sicher wir kriegen balten
impfstoff und wir sind sehen auch licht
am ende des tunnels aber jetzt ist es
wirklich wichtig dass wir diesen
lockdown richtig machen dass er auch
wichtig wirkt denn nur dann kommen wir
schwatten wir wieder wie beim letzten an
der überfüllung der intensivstation
vorbei und das ist das letzte was wir
wollen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren